mais tout d'abord cette frayeur dans le
quartier des casernes à Tours quartiers
qui a été bouclé après la découverte de
bouteilles suspectes c'est une équipe
d'archéologues d'archéologues pardon de
l'INRA qui est tombé nez-année avec 10
bons de gaz datant de la première ou
Seconde Guerre mondiale un périmètre de
sécurité a été mise en place cet
après-midi sur place Aurélie Renaud
sur le site des casernes Beaumont 4
archéologues travaillent sous ces tantes
à la recherche de vestiges grâce à une
pelle mécanique ils enlèvent la terre
subitement il heurte un objet une
bouteille qui a été accrochée et une
autre qui s'est renversée et le liquide
qui s'est mis à sortir de la bouteille
comme mousser et le sable qui était
autour est devenu tout noir donc ils ont
compris qu'il y avait un problème les
quatre archéologues ont été incommodés
par du gaz moutarde ils sont
immédiatement transportés au CHU et en
ressort indemne quelques heures plus
tard 30 pompiers sont diligentés au
casernes dont la cellule d'intervention
chimique le quartier est alors bouclé
cet après-midi on craignait une
propagation via un nuage chimique
crainte dissipée à présent mais au total
il y aurait bien dix bouteilles de gaz
moutarde stockées sur le site
on est sur un sur un gaz
un gaz qui est utilisé par les
militaires mais pour le moment qu'il n'a
pas qui n'a pas développé un nuage
toxique donc on n'est pas sur des des
risques importants on veut juste
s'assurer que il n'y a pas de risque
pour notamment les personnels
intervenants et notamment les futurs
fouilles archéologiques à la mi-journée
la bouteille de gaz est ventrée a été
calfeutrée par la cellule de risque
chimiques les démineurs arriveront ce
soir la décision a été prise de bâcher
la bouteille qui est fuyarde ce qui
permet de sécuriser le périmètre et on
est sûr que il y aura pas obligation
d'étendre un périmètre et d'évacuer les
habitants autour de ce périmètre le site
des casernes Beaumont reste inaccessible
les opérations de déminage elle
débuteront demain matin ainsi les rues
voisines des casernes seront fermées